[Musique]
et c'est barbon soit qu'elle rentrait
quelle forme
vous voilà toute âme ainsi sur ce que
vous appelez votre votre petit matelas
de popularité je crois que mon petit
matelas est une expression qui a eu qui
a eu du succès dans ce que je voulais
dire simplement c'est que j'étais
j'étais resté assez paisible je n'avais
pas été un agité au cours de ces
derniers mois et qu'en dépit de cela je
constatais que les français me
manifestait encore leur confiance et
leur sympathie
c'est ce qui me donne la possibilité de
m'exprimer
monsieur bah renvoi de semaine en
semaine
des affaires qui éclatent et qui
entachent les partis politiques les
hommes politiques les grand nombre
d'entreprises françaises
vous estimez que cette opération ces
révélations sont saines qu'il faut aller
encore plus loin pour assainir le climat
en france où vous pensez que déjà les
jugements trop loin mesdames les
révélations quand elles se rapportent à
des faits qui existent ne peuvent pas
être considérés comme malsaine ou scène
elles décrivent une situation contre
laquelle il faut s'efforcer de lutte et
je crois que il faut que la justice
puisse suivre son cours sans aucune
interférence
les français croient souvent que selon
que l'on est puissant ou misérable
l'injustice n'exerce pas pour les
premiers s'exercent pour les seconds
exemple leurs dépenses dans certains cas
il est certain que des interférences se
produise il faut que des législations
soit adoptée la loi sapin aller dans une
bonne direction mais à mon avis et cette
loi doit être renforcée en particulier
pour tout ce qui concerne les opérations
qui sont menées dans le cadre de la
décentralisation est ce qu'il faut je
crois
réussir à régler à obtenir
c'est une grande transparence voilà les
conditions qui sont nécessaires pour
qu'un climat de confiance de de moralité
publique se rétablisse les français ils
sont très attachés c'est la raison pour
laquelle parmi les objectifs que j'avais
retenu dans ma lettre faisait arguments
j'avais mis en tête la restauration de
la dignité de l'état et de la dignité de
l'administration
[Musique]